I feel like you can totally wear this
shirt all commando and like no nips are
showing this is the quality the shirt
that you're getting anonymous nippleless
[Music]
okay this is definitely a white dress
shirt
well no Dov nailed it so off the bat you
can see that it has like really nice
material
there's like some kind of pattern
texture yeah versus just like a plain
white dress shirt it's pretty thick it's
slim fit but you can get cheap slim fits
I've gotten fat or slim fits the texture
is like really soft and you don't get
this for cheap you know sometimes you
get like a white dress shirt it's almost
like see-through like that yeah and yeah
this is better than that oh yeah is
there a place to put a cuff link no I
would say this shirt is $55 I'm gonna
say this sure it's like $75 I'm gonna
get retail this is $39.99 I'm just gonna
agree with you
$39.99 sounds like a solid thanks for
those $19.99 I see 30 1999 you don't get
this texture oh oh
34 this way $20 oh I would not pay $79
for this you know just from looking at
it and feeling like how it feels I can
automatically tell that this is probably
$20 yeah this has this has the feel of
like how can you go like that's how much
he has well it's like a casual white
dress
it's like rough it is I don't know if I
could call this a dress shirt usually
for me like if it's a dress shirt I
could put on a blazer or I could put on
like some kind of an accent to it
I like this shirt it's it's nice and
thick it's one where you don't need to
iron it cuz like the wrinkly part of its
like part of the style this is the white
dress shirt you see like dudes wear add
like a wedding or something where it's
like that guy doesn't have a nice dress
shirt and he's like wearing his one
white shirt it's always kind of wrinkly
yeah sure so this is Brennan shirt this
is my this is the one I would have I
would guess 1499 25
I would guess this shirt is $24 agree I
think don't wanna say 30 bucks I'm gonna
guess that this is Old Navy and put it
at oh nice
this has to be thank you soon this yeah
that then Houston's like user the twelve
dollar ones I buy this is very vain
please to me looking the buttons on this
one are actually like white and not
ivory nice and buttons mean it's
actually a nicer shirt this does have
like a soft texture that we saw in the
first one and also the cuffs the cuffs
are like really nice and sturdy this is
pretty see-through I think this is
definitely sold at an outlet mall it's
definitely a shirt that it's going to
cost a little bit more for like the way
the cuff is I feel like the way the
collar is I'd say 79 I'm gonna say $85 I
mean I can pretty confidently call this
one 15 bucks I'm gonna say $24.97 I feel
like it's like 80 bucks for 60 I want to
say this is 45 oh I see 45 - oh this
feels like very synthetic just doesn't
feel like cotton to me it's like a
little bit see-through you can see your
nips through it all the nipples can be
seen under it this feels like the shirt
that you get when you rent your prom tux
yes absolutely it's more fitted yeah
what does that mean so when you tuck it
into your pants it's not gonna like
muffin top you it's probably something
that it's easily accessible for
everybody and the fabric is a little bit
more stretchy like feel the stretchiness
with woah it's so stretchy
heck I guess maybe like 20 dollars
knowledge but I want I'm gonna say $19
just to be different I didn't get my
$14.99 before of their own $14.99 on
this one well I'm gonna hype all this at
$59.99 $12.99 I don't say 60 oh geez
shut up
this is $135 I will say them I don't
knock on the higher priced shirts just
because I do feel like it's an
investment and if you're willing to
invest it will last you longer you've
got an air B&B in Maui for the price of
some of these shirts you can live
without a shirt in Maui that's what I
would do vacation more chocolates